i have this four by four matrix a here
and let's see if we can figure out its
determinant the determinant of a and
before just doing it the way we've done
it in the past where you go down one of
the rows or one of the columns and you
notice there's no zeros here so there's
no easy row or easy column to take the
determinant by you know we could have
gone down this row and do all the sub
matrices but this becomes pretty
involved you end up doing four
three by three determinants and then
that's complete each of those are
composed of three two by two
determinants becomes a pretty hairy
process let's see if we can use some of
the realizations we've discovered in the
last few videos to simplify this process
well one of the realizations is that row
operations or if you subtract
let me write it this way
if you replace
row
row j
with
let's say rho
j minus some scalar multiple times
rho
rho i it does not change the determinant
does not change
the determinant of a
we saw that i think it was two videos
ago so this was a pretty big realization
we can do these type of row operations
and it won't change the determinant the
other realization we had was that these
upper triangular matrices upper
triangular
matrices
you can figure out their determinant so
what does upper triangular look like let
me just review it the upper triangular
everything below the diagonal so let's
say the diagonal has let me just draw
its terms like that these are some
non-zero terms or they don't have to be
then upper triangular upper triangular
everything below the diagonal is a zero
and everything above the diagonal may
probably isn't a zero but you never know
but they're non-zero term so all the red
stuff here is non-zero all the stuff in
green is zero i didn't touch on in that
video but there is also such a thing as
a lower triangular
lower triangular that you might have
guessed how it looks everything above
the main diagonal is zero so this is the
main diagonal right here
all the way down like that all of these
guys are going to be non-zero
all of that's going to be non-zero and
then the zeros are going to be above the
tri above the diagonal
like that
we saw in the last video that the
determinant of this guy is just equal to
the product of the diagonal entries
which is a very
good or it's a very simple way of
finding a determinant and you could use
the same argument we made in the last
video to say that the same is true of
the lower triangular matrix that its
determinant is also just the product of
those entries
i won't prove it here but you can use
the exact same argument you used in the
video that i just did on the upper
triangular so given this that the
determinant of this is just the product
of those guys and that i can perform row
operations on this guy and not change
the determinant maybe a simpler way to
calculate this determinant is to get
this guy into an upper triangular form
and then just multiply the entries down
the diagonal so let's do that
so we want to find the determinant of a
so the determinant of a
let me rewrite a right here it's
1 two two
one
one two
four two
two
seven
five
two
minus one
four
minus 6
3.
now let's put this in let's try to get
this into upper triangular form
so
if we
let's replace the second row with the
second so i'm just going to keep the
first row the same
one two two
one and let's replace the second row the
second row with the second row minus the
first row the second row minus the first
row is going to be equal to one minus
one
is zero so in this case the constant is
just one so one minus one is zero two
minus two is
zero four minus two is two
two minus one is one
now let's replace the
let's replace the third row with the
third row minus two times the second row
so two minus two times one is zero
seven minus two times two is three
five minus two times two is one
two minus two times
one is
zero
and then let's let me get a good color
here
do pink
let's replace
let's replace the last row with the last
row
essentially plus the first row you could
say minus minus 1 times the first row
which is the same thing as the last row
plus the first row so minus 1 plus 1 is
four plus two is six
minus six plus two minus six plus two is
minus four
and then three plus one is four
is four so there we have it like that
and this guy has two zeros here so maybe
i want to swap some rows so let me swap
some rows so if we swap rows what
happens
so let me right i'm gonna swap the
middle two rows just for fun well not
just for fun i don't because i want a
pivot entry right here or i shouldn't
say pivot entry i want to do an upper
triangular form so i want a non-zero
entry here this is a zero so i'm going
to move this guy down so i'm going to
keep the top row the same one two two
one i'm gonna keep the bottom row the
same 0
0 6
minus 4
4 and i'm going to swap these guys right
here
so this is going to be 0
1 0 and then 0 0 2 1. now can i just
swap entries like that well i can but
you have to remember that when you swap
entries your resulting determinant is
going to be the negative of your
original determinant so if we swap these
two guys the determinant of this is
going to be the negative the negative of
this determinant when you swap two rows
you just flip the sign of the
determinant we saw that that was one of
the first videos we did on these kind of
messing with the determinants
now what do we want to do here to get
this this guy into upper triangular form
to get this upper triangular form it'd
be nice to get this to be a zero so to
get that to be a zero
let me keep everything else the same so
i have a one two
two one i have a zero
three one zero the third row is zero
zero
two one and now this last row
let me replace it with the last row
minus three times this row so let me
write it like this well i have to carry
that negative sign as well so i'm going
to replace this last row with the last
row minus three times
or this last row minus two times the
second row
i want to zero it out
so 0 minus 2 times 0 is 0 6 minus 2
times 3 is 0 minus 4 minus 2 times 1 is
-6 and then 4 minus 2 times 0 is just 4.
we're almost there
now we want to zero what do we want to
do we want to zero this guy out so let's
replace
this one
so i'm going to keep my top three rows
the same again and let me see if i can
write a little bit neater so my first
row is one two
two
one my second row is zero
three one zero fourth row is zero zero
and i'm going to take the matrix i
haven't written the fourth row yet and
of course this is going to the negative
of this
is going to be the determinant of our
original matrix because we had swapped
those rows but let's replace this last
row
let's replace the last row with the last
row plus three times three times the
third row so we get zero plus three
times zero is zero zero plus three times
zero is zero
minus six plus three times two is 0
4 plus 3 times 1 is 7.
and just like that we have a determinant
of a matrix in upper triangular form
so this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to the product
of these guys
so this is going to be equal to can't
forget our negative sign let's throw a
negative sign out there
and put a parenthesis just like
this is going to be the product of that
diagonal entry 1 times 3
times 3 times 2 times 7 which is 6 times
7 which is 42
42 so the determinant of this matrix is
minus 42 which was pretty fast this was
a pretty fast shortcut and actually
turns out it tends to be computationally
more efficient to use these takeaways to
put things into upper triangular form
first and then you know if you do swaps
you have to remember to make the
determinant negative and then just
multiply down the diagonal and we did
that there we got the determinant as
being minus 42.